in the ever-expanding dc extended
universe there are a number of
storylines plot points and narrative
threads that have disappeared without
explanation it doesn't mean they'll
never return of course but for now these
are all major unfinished business for
the growing dceu
the film that kicked off the dc eu as we
know it was man of steel it followed the
evolution of one clark kent played by
henry cavill from small town american
alien boy to becoming superman in the
process he faces villains from his
long-lost kryptonian heritage primarily
general zod played by michael shannon
and his renegade soldiers after they
escaped from imprisonment in the phantom
zone zod's genocidal plan was to use the
world engine kryptonian technology that
can terraform a world into one
inhabitable for kryptonians on earth the
result would be an earth remade in the
image of krypton and suitable for
kryptonian life but at the cost of its
existing life zod's own ship the black
zero contributed towards the
terraforming on one end of the planet
with the world engine sitting over the
indian ocean here's the thing the
terraforming process would affect all
life on earth including the oceans and
the world engine was operating directly
over the indian ocean we know from dc
history and aquaman that the atlanteans
are extremely sensitive to changes in or
mistreatment of the world's oceans also
they have strong weaponry and
technologically advanced vehicles given
what we know there's no reason why they
wouldn't respond to the world engine
perceiving it as an attack against their
seas and sovereignty while superman did
halt its efforts somewhat quickly it's
surprising they didn't react where were
they that was more pressing than this
terraforming attack
batman vs superman dawn of justice is
the first dceu film to incorporate the
dark knight himself folding batman in
after he spent 20 years fighting crime
in gotham at this point batman played by
ben affleck is a hardened and more
violent vigilante even taking to
branding criminals and he works alone
with the help of alfred when we see the
bad cave one of its more haunting pieces
is a damaged robin costume in a glass
case with hahaha jokes on you batman
spray painted across the front there are
bullet holes in the suit but there's
little in the film to explain its
backstory we know a few key pieces of
backstory from subsequent comments and
films harley quinn's introduction in
suicide squad lists her as an accomplice
to robin's murder this admittedly causes
problems for the intended timelines of
both snyder and suicide squad director
david ayer joker has his gold grill in
his mouth upon meeting harley but it is
said to have appeared as a result of
batman beating him in retaliation for
robin's death if that's the case when
and how did the joker actually kill
robin and what was harley's actual
relation to that crime
talking about the lack of clarity over
robin's death in the dc eu highlights
exactly how little we know about
batman's 20-year history of fighting
crime in gotham in a telling line to
alfred bruce wayne laments 20 years in
gotham afrin
we've seen what promises are worth
how many good guys are left
how many stayed that way the line
suggests that fellow vigilantes have
fallen like robin and perhaps turn to
crime in suicide squad we see killer
croc and watch the caped crusader chase
joker and harley quinn and elsewhere
intervene to capture deadshot but other
than some big generalities we know
almost nothing about batman's history in
gotham or with these villains nor the
vigilantes that have supported his
crusade plus most of the dceu has moved
on instead of clarifying any of these
emissions what's the history of this
batman and his allies and conflicts how
did it contribute toward his actions in
batman vs superman you're out of your
mind bruce wayne
in justice league we see the first war
between earth's forces and the forces of
darkseid that took place 5 000 years ago
regardless of the version both showed a
green lantern fighting alongside earth's
forces then dying in the battle with its
power ring flying off to find a new
lantern lanterns essentially protect
sectors of space and will intervene in
situations on a planet they specialize
in protecting from extraterrestrial
threats invasions and other space-based
attackers most importantly sectors
shouldn't go without a protector which
is why the ring sought a new lantern
immediately so where were the lanterns
over the last 5 000 years where were the
lanterns when zod and the kryptonians
attacked earth in man of steel where
were they when doomsday emerged in
batman vs superman or especially in
justice league when another
extraterrestrial invasion occurred these
are exactly the sorts of interstellar
conflicts that green lanterns are
supposed to respond to and while we see
green lanterns in an upcoming hbo max
series it makes little sense that they'd
set out these subsequent interstellar
assaults
in shazam the dc eu opens up its magical
side in the film the rock of eternity is
said to be the source of all magic as
well as the place where the seven deadly
sins are kept the original wizard shazam
and his seven family members formed the
council of wizards there at some point
in the past shazam gave teth adam later
known as black adam powers in that realm
the conflict pitting black adam and the
unleashed seven deadly sins against the
council of wizards resulted in the
deaths of most of the latter
considerable time passed before shazam
transferred his powers to billy batson
and later billy's own shazam family to
fight the newly released seven deadly
sins and the villainous dr savannah
certainly a lot will be explained about
black adam in subsequent films but in
the comics he began life as an egyptian
slave putting the events that killed
most of the council of wizards
approximately around 5 000 years ago
this is exactly when the atlanteans
amazons and early humans fought the
forces of darkseid in justice league if
the council of wizards were around where
were they when evil alien gods were
invading gods atlanteans and amazons
were all there yet the wizards didn't
show up to protect the earth at this
pivotal time
in batman vs superman dawn of justice
lex luthor played by jesse eisenberg
wages a multi-pronged attack on superman
it involved many steps from blowing up
the united states capital to kidnapping
superman's mom in a moment of
justification he claims that his
motivation is basically being against
the notion of gods on earth he argues
that devils don't come from hell beneath
us rather they come from the sky so
clearly he sees superman as an evil
enemy he also shares his interesting
argument of a divine being if god is
all-powerful
he cannot be all good
and if he is all good
then he cannot be all-powerful
ultimately we aren't really given other
reasons for luther to hate superman in
the comics luther is said to have a long
history and personal vendetta against
him not so here the only reason we have
is luther's supposed disdain for gods
that have power above humans luther's
final plan beyond his convoluted massive
tactics involves mixing his own blood
with zod's body combining the two with
kryptonian technology to create doomsday
the ultra
behemoth that kills superman so his
motivating factor is apparently a hatred
of gods and yet his final plan is to
engineer a god that's more powerful more
animalistic and less subject to human
control that's not what a brilliant
planner would do with that motivation so
what's luther's real incentive for
absolutely hating superman
regarding luther's engineering of the
doomsday monster in batman vs superman
dawn of justice the process makes
relatively little sense lex enters the
genesis chamber of the kryptonian scout
ship using zod's fingerprints and
command key he's talked the wealth of
knowledge from the kryptonian archives
learning of an ancient kryptonian
monster aka doomsday that he recreates
as a failsafe if batman can't or doesn't
kill superman the process involves
bringing zod's corpse into the genesis
chamber then luther cutting himself and
bleeding into the chamber and onto zod
the resultant engineering feat is a
version of the recreation of doomsday
it's an effectively mindless creature
with immense strength at least on par
with if not stronger than superman
boundless rage and some serious
regenerative abilities what makes little
sense is why corrupting kryptonian dna
with human dna made such a strong if not
stronger entity than superman humans
look like kryptonians in every relevant
way but doomsday is larger than either
and looks like neither kryptonians are
massively stronger on earth than humans
are and doomsday seems stronger than
kryptonians despite the addition of
human dna adding human dna wouldn't be
the recipe to make this ancient beast
because it's unlikely that its ancient
kryptonian creator had humans lying
around why in the world would blending
kryptonian dna with human dna not make
doomsday a hybrid of the two thus weaker
than superman it makes little sense in
batman vs superman dawn of justice bruce
wayne is woken from a nightmare by a
vision of barry allen aka the flash he
offers bruce a warning about the future
albeit vague and confusing saying bruce
listen to me now it's lois it's lois
lane she's the key
you're right about him
you've always been right about him
in zack snyder's justice league superman
succumbs to the anti-life equation and
under darkseid's rule lays waste to many
of his enemies the flash we can infer
went back in time to warn batman about
superman's inherent danger of course
this was a plot thread that the dc eu
didn't move forward with so there's a
high chance it will never be fulfilled
and we only see in part where it may
have been intended to go at the same
time the flash sequence still exists
within dceu continuity but it's unclear
how they're going to try to give it
finality and meaning if at all
in wonder woman 1984 the fbi turned to
dr barbara minerva to aid in the
identification of the wish-granting
dreamstone failing businessman maxwell
lord wishes to become the stone itself
it grants him the ability to gain power
every time someone makes a wish through
him he uses this to eventually take over
the white house secretive u.s
communications technologies and
effectively the whole world as he grants
the wishes of humanity all these wishes
come with a cost to their users of
course and it all pushes humanity nearly
to the point of global nuclear war
wonder woman uses her lasso of truth on
lord convincing the world including lord
to end the crisis by renouncing their
wishes but even though there's no
indication that renouncing wishes made
anyone forget the events that just
occurred on a global scale the movie
just sort of moves on if everyone on
earth was allowed to make wishes that
came true causing massive global chaos
that would change human history
civilization and religion as we know it
it would reveal the existence of magic
which is a big deal and publicly
confirmed the existence of metahumans as
early as the 1980s it would change
literally everything in the dc eu but
instead it was dropped like it wasn't a
big deal
that's the truth in suicide squad amanda
waller builds a team of expendable super
villains to go on dangerous missions in
the wake of superman's death in exchange
for commuted prison sentences the main
exception is dr june moon who is
possessed by an ancient interdimensional
sorceress known as enchantress when
enchantress and her ancient brother
incubus moved to take over earth the
pair use magic to turn a variety of
people into their supernatural soldiers
the odd thing about all this is that the
villains here are clearly magical
mystical threats and waller knows this
even still most of the members of the
suicide squad have literally no mystical
abilities or relation to magic this is a
major oversight because the only reason
the team succeeds is due to the efforts
of its somewhat magical members for
example el diablo uses his cursed full
fire form to fight incubus and push him
over a bomb waller knows enchantress is
a sorceress so why send an ill-chosen
team for a magical job was the us
government so uninterested in magic that
they never bothered to have good
contingency plans against magic attacks
and have they gotten any better on that
front check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite dc movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]